Zoe a difficult game yesterday but an
immediate recovery in today's game first
of all congratulations it was at this
moment that it seemed like finally after
the move night uh H5 excuse me you got
the move E4 on the board so G6 for black
isn't the best move I think it's
supposed to be some Bishop D7 or
something all the way here yeah okay
because Jesus kind of weakens the Kings
I didn't really see the point to it and
um so then I had some extra turns to
play the F34 idea once I get E4 and I
think I'm better already you are yeah
yeah not only better maybe just winning
objectively winning at this point I
thought after she played C5 I was kind
of releasing my advantage because
doesn't she have some sort of F5 later
perhaps but it seems like the computer
always said that you're in control it
looked difficult during the game in fact
at this point it felt like maybe she's
getting some tricks in really here was
where I was like oh my gosh I'm up in
exchange I must be winning did you see
this idea of Bishop takes two uh
I didn't consider taking the pawn I was
just like Rook D2 sort of with Tempo
threatening Rook F2 it's safer so you
felt uh the danger in that position very
nice Rook to D2 and after that you
finished uh quite nicely in style
with Rook takes F7 my Rook F7 was nice I
didn't see it until the move happened
Zoe tell us about your Ambitions because
so far you're doing amazing in this
event sure a difficult game yesterday
but you're still in this tournament
you're here to win it but my ambitions
are still the same as the first round I
still don't want to embarrass myself I
want to play good chess and I'm not too
concerned with results I mean I start
off what fifth seed it doesn't really
matter right three and a half out of
five quite a very good decent results so
far guys any questions well for me
congratulations and the the final
position the final combination was a
real visual it was a beautiful finish
Zoe well done thank you absolutely and a
lot of results are coming in